[Musique]
matteo raccoon city
espérons cinq noms à retenir et chacun
dans leur style cinq découvertes qui
mérite qu'on tende l'oreille vous
reconnaissez ce ver d'oreille
c'est le groupe clé m fraize sacré
révélation dans la catégorie chanson
parce que les personnes qui écoutent
créé en france il oublie complètement
leurs problèmes
matteo et la révélation musiques du
monde le monde est vaste comme le talent
et les influences de matteo on inclut
deux éléments afrobeat et salsa rock et
avec une touche jamaïcain dans les
groupes bel arrêt
alors là mais là au haillan
nouveauté cette année la catégorie
révélation rap c'est raccoon city qu est
le premier lauréat dire après manon
piste lors de trois mètres la cour isna
je vais apporter un petit peu d'espoir
pour les jeunes qui vont un peu se
reconnaître en moi aussi je veux montrer
que que que le rap sera long car mayotte
est la révélation jazz un style qu'il
aime explorer qui le rend accessible
j'aime choisir java que je le mets ou
quelles frontières je vais assez d'aller
chercher les plus que je peux aller
chercher dans tous les styles musicaux
[Musique]
vous avez la 2e espérons commencer le
violon à deux ans et a donné ses
premiers concerts l'âge de 5 ans
le prix révélation classique n'est pas
son premier plus prestigieux je me sens
vraiment le plus chez moi quand je fais
la musique puis 1
j'adore pouvoir partager ça avec les
gens
et
aucun doute la cuvée 2020 est un grand
millésime
à consommer sans modération ici n'est
dit alexandre charti radio canada
montréal
[Musique]